le lunch pendant deux jours des fruits
des rafraîchissements et l'hospitalité
pour des ânes à garcia sait tous que lui
aura coûté l'installation d'un système
de panneaux sont ils sont posés par une
dizaine d'ouvriers bénévoles d'une ong
grid alternatif gratis cadeau de l'état
de californie
mais garcia ne sont pas très riche terna
et son mari travaille alors cinq enfants
sont aux études vivre en périphérie de
sacramento leur donne de l'espace mais
aussi de sacrés facture d'électricité
climatisation indispensable un peu de
chauffage mais surtout ne pompe à eau
qui coûte cher et après quatre ans de
sécheresse d anna a dû renoncer à son
élevage de chèvres plus question
d'arroser le pâturage comme avant la
facture en été peut monter jusqu'à 900 $
paria fenêtres isolantes plus panneaux
solaires égale des économique énorme
voici comment le fonds d'investissement
climatiques de la californie se
financent quatre fois par an dans une
salle de son siège social
l' agence de protection de
l'environnement de la californie
organisé via internet une vente aux
enchères de crédits de carbone
elle dure trois heures est allé sous
stricte surveillance d'experts externes
ce sont les industries qui ne peuvent ou
ne veulent pas réduire leurs
missions qui doivent acheter les crédits
de carbone depuis 2014 le québec
participent à la même vente aux enchères
ce sera demain la cinquième la
californie à plafonner les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de toutes les
industries au niveau de 1990 d'ici 2020
le québec veut parvenir à 20% en dessous
de 1990 la californie n'avait pas le
choix que de lutter contre les
changements climatiques le sud aride
pris pour de la pluie qui n'est pas
tombé depuis quatre ans il veut qu'on
lui envoie de l'eau des bassins et des
réservoirs du nord de l'état
sauf que leurs réserves diminuent car
les cours d'eau ne sont plus autant
alimenté par les neiges de la sierra
nevada
il ne reste presque plus conséquence de
la sécheresse
les arbres sont ravagés par les insectes
et particulièrement l'été dernier par
les feux de forêt
de ce fait nous sommes au et les siens
campus d'innovation de technologie verte
tout juste inauguré par la ville de los
angeles
dépolluer en innovant tout en faisant de
l'argent c'est l'objectif c'est le même
principe que pour le cap and trade
la bourse du carbone on donne un prix de
la valeur au carbone une bourse à
laquelle va bientôt se joindre l'ontario
d'où la présence en californie de la
première ministre kathy plusieurs
provinces et états nord-américains n'ont
pas voulu attendre leurs gouvernements
centraux pour hacher l'état de new york
aimerait entraîner d'autres états de
nouvelle angleterre dans le système
californienne jusqu'à maintenant les
résultats sont très encourageants
ici en californie
un succès est un exemple trois mots
d'amour
je pense que dans le canada c'est
important pour les autres provinces
d'avoir un exemple de cas la famille et
deux de québec pour pourra décider si
c'est un système fort pour lui la beauté
du système c'est qu'il rapporte de
l'argent
600 millions de dollars pour la
californie en un seul ans quand il y en
a 4 par an une centaine de millions de
dollars pour le québec
dans les deux cas tout ça s'en va dans
un fond vert
l'argent du fonds il sert à beaucoup de
choses
à aider l'agriculture verte et économe
en eau panneaux solaires pour pomper
l'eau irrigation au goutte à goutte
il sert à favoriser l'acquisition de
voitures électriques ou hybrides
on veut améliorer les transports en
commun vers
en plus la californie un projet colossal
un train à grande vitesse entre san
francisco et san diego 800 kg rennes
mais il a du mal à décoller ce sera le
premier en amérique
voici la vision
la réalité c'est encore ça de façon plus
modeste la petite production électrique
de derna donnera cette compagnie
municipale quelques crédits verts ou
bien les drass à petite échelle à
réduire ses émissions de gaz